anime fans love to disagree whether it's
a debate over their favorite anime
or the most underrated one or the best
waifu
sandra gahara is the only right option
by the way i'm taking no other responses
there will always be discord but in a
field that is so
defined by its contradictions and people
wielding their different opinions like a
katana coated in cheeto dust they bought
for five dollars from an anime
convention
i believe there is always one universal
constant the god
equation of anime if you will one that
can forever and
always bring us together under one big
sweaty otaku umbrella
that constant being of course that anime
openings
slap no matter what you think of an
anime the characters the plot whatever
what we can all agree on is whether it
had a good opening
no questions asked every couple of
months a saint arrives onto youtube to
give a ranking of the best anime
openings of all time this
is the most recent one i saw and you
know that those videos are copyright
claimed to hell
so the people making them are doing it
purely out of the goodness of their
heart and dedication to the millions of
fans who love
anime openings and these lists actually
usually only have a few small
differences between them
sometimes a new show brings a great new
opening like with jiu-jitsu kaisen
recently
or maybe a list fails to include
openings of shows because
well the person making the list just
hasn't seen them or perhaps one of the
most popular just
wasn't among their tastes but there will
always be ones that stick around your
unravels
your brave shines your hikaru naras
and it really made me wonder what about
these openings specifically
made them so distinctly memorable and
amazing
is it the visuals is it just the music
is it the atmosphere and the tone of it
all
what makes a great anime opening
well i of course could just give my
personal opinions but i don't think the
words of one man could explain such a
widespread phenomenon
so i put on my researcher glasses and
looked at the connections
what tied together all of the best anime
openings
i first checked out the most recent
video to blow up on this topic one that
i watched a while ago back when new is
recommended to me and i compiled the top
20 songs on it
with the exception of the 20th pick the
opening for elfin lead
all 20 songs are bangers meaning they're
the kinds of tracks that get you excited
your blood
pumping your head bopping to the
insanely exciting japanese rock music
and you might be thinking i mean aren't
all openings are all good
openings just solid japanese rock music
anyway
isn't it a given that they're all like
that well
yes and no though the motif of having
japanese rock as
anime openings is a common trope one
that frankly dominates the market
it's not done in all anime some of my
favorite openings such as
monsters
[Music]
or mushy's
both sacrificed the hype of an opening
for the atmosphere
for setting a specific tone a worthy
trade in my opinion a very dark brooding
one for the former and
a relaxing introspective mood for the
latter
and so even though it is free reign for
the animation company to choose what
kind of opening the show will have
whether they prefer to focus on the feel
of it rather than its overall hype and
attraction
it does often fall on japanese rock
music just because
well clearly they succeed recognizing an
anime opening is synonymous with
recognizing the anime itself it is such
an
important part of the series to fans and
the companies making them
i remember absolutely nothing from tokyo
ghoul season 1
except kaneki counting down by sevens
and the opening
but even though the monster and mushishi
opening are instantly recognizable in my
opinion to
any fans of said series or anyone who
remembers them at all really
they would never be seen on one of these
lists of the best openings out there
even though i love them i also wouldn't
put them here on my own list
and i suppose that this is enough
evidence that that hype
something that atmospheric openings
often don't have is
one of if not the most important parts
of a good opening song
even if it's not japanese rock
specifically or even rock music in
general
it is almost always an upbeat fast bpm
song
in the upper echelons of anime openings
looking at another list we've got the
same names i mentioned before
unravel brave shine hikaru nara but
we've also got songs like the cowboy
bebop opening
attack on titans good and no yumiya and
one piece's first opening we
are which aren't along the conventional
japanese rock we normally see
cowboy bebops is jazz fusion guerino
yumiya is hard rock almost
on the precipice of metal one pieces we
are is just
i don't know what we are is frankly and
i discovered an interesting connection
between all of these songs
one that are highly ranked but don't
follow the typical formula
and it's that almost all of them are
songs made only for the anime
as i was saying earlier openings are
crucial in creating an anime and making
it recognizable
and many times studios will actually
reach out to record labels or artists to
make songs
just for the anime itself instead of
using a song that's already been made
in the case of seatbelts the band that
produced the forever iconic opening and
soundtrack of cowboy bebop
the compuser yoko kano formed the band
for the sole
purpose of making music for cowboy bebop
which
explains its god tier ost i mean they
assembled like the avengers just to make
the music for this one show
likewise there are obvious instances
such as one punch man's opening where
they scream
one punch or stein's gates opening
hacking to the gate
where the song has been made solely for
the anime opening
where the lyrics and the visuals and the
mood all coalesce as a perfect intro to
the show
now the reason that every anime doesn't
do this even though it seems like a
great idea
one that has historically panned out
very well in creating a very iconic
opening that is emblematic of the anime
is because it costs more money frankly
it's easier to just get rights to a song
that's already
been made instead of making one from
scratch and
finding composers to do it but anyway
the purpose of this long tangent here
was basically trying to say that
as long as it's pretty hype and exciting
like all of these openings
are regardless of whether it is
specifically made for the show or not
it'll probably do well there's no
specific connection that i could find
between whether openings made for the
anime do better than ones that aren't so
in my eyes it's pretty clear that this
is not a key factor but
it can help if you've got the funds
so what is hype excitement the only
thing you really need to make a good
opening
there's there's no way that's it right
well let's
look a bit deeper before we settle on
that conclusion
i believe personally that something that
is incredibly fundamentally important to
how memorable an opening song is
is actually the opening's opening
the very first word said or the very
first sound you hear
the sonic q that sends shivers down your
spine
opens the floodgates of endorphins
and i think it can be done in many ways
one example is
lyrically many openings begin with a
short
maybe one or two lines of just lyrics
either no music at all or very minimal
backing track
and right after the lines finish an epic
drop into the beat and rhythm of the
song
and this is certainly one of the most
memorable ways for fans to start off any
opening
full metal alchemist brotherhood opening
[Music]
one
naruto shippuden opening 6.
[Music]
it is a very popular way to approach it
and why is that
well for one it's a good way to ease
into the episode
openings almost always come either at
the very beginning of the episode or
after a short
two to three minute beginning section or
cold open either way
having a short vocal part to kick off
the more upbeat and banging opening
reels us back in gradually as we start
the new episode
and very quickly sets off the trigger to
get ready for what is to come
plus more so than anything lyrics are
always
very very memorable even if you're not
fluent in japanese
i mean i could recite the beginning of
any of these openings here because
they're classic
it gets stuck in your mind just like any
good song does
it's truly proof of the fact that music
has no language barriers at all
and then there's also the openings with
no language at all actually
just a single audio cue the moment you
hear this one audio cue
you know what song it is stein's gate
code eos it is a subtle
but instantly recognizable introduction
to the song
and i would argue that the main
difference between this and lyrics is
that the instrumental is just
a single moment that'll trigger any
weeb's spidey senses the moment it
begins
it once again reminds us that
recognizing an opening
means recognizing an anime but because
there are so many famous openings that
don't follow this format ones that jump
right into the music like your line
april's opening
or bloody stream from jojo's bizarre
adventure or silhouette from naruto
it's it's too difficult to say this is a
fundamental part of an anime opening
being great
and so once again we come back full
circle to the hype
the excitement and i think after 10 or
so minutes of discussing this
i think i'm mentally prepared to accept
the fact that
maybe being exciting really is the most
important
underlying factor above all that is
needed for any anime opening to become
really widespread and unanimously
popular and yes i know there are
exceptions
i have exceptions of my own to this rule
but it seems after all the time i've
taken to research into
small one and a half minute snippets of
songs across a variety of anime
more so than atmospheric effect and tone
or how the song begins or whether it's
made specifically with the anime in mind
making sure the audience just recognizes
it and gets hyped to it
seems to be what will always reign
supreme
what are your thoughts it's it's a
rather bittersweet conclusion to arrive
at but the thing is
i love hype anime openings too they're
my favorite i think there's something
fundamentally
connecting anime to exciting music that
naturally appeals to all fans
but anyway leave a comment on what you
think
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoy the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you